lauren duvernay tardif of the kansas
city chiefs the first player and the
only player so far to opt out of the
2020 season he is a doctor he explained
friday night on social media being at
the front line during this offseason has
given me a different perspective on this
pandemic and the stress it puts on
individuals and our healthcare system i
cannot allow myself to potentially
transmit the virus in our communities
simply to play the sport that i love if
i am to take risks i will do it caring
for patients that's a strong statement
and i think that statement may have been
lost on some of the teammates and
coaches that praised him what he's
basically saying is none of us should be
doing this none of us should be
potentially transmitting the virus in
our communities just to play football
now he's not preaching but that's the
inescapable conclusion he doesn't
believe it's justified this year chris
we'll see whether or not others agree
with him whether it's for that more
humanitarian reason like
uh lauren duvernay tardif has utilized
or whether it's i'm worried about myself
i'm worried about family members
i'm just not comfortable this year
whatever the case may be they have
another week to tap out if they're going
to tap out if you do it it's irrevocable
and if you let august 3 pass without
doing it you are locked in you cannot
walk away there is one limited exception
you can have a change circumstances
where if someone close to you gets sick
or dies over it then you can say okay
hey hey hang on i'm out right but
for the most part if you are still there
a week from now you're there all season
long and if you leave you're breaching
your contract well you know
again this is a this is a different guy
you know this is this is uh first off
he's a doctor yeah he's extremely smart
we know that he's been on the front line
here so he's really had a lot of
experiences dealing with the you know
kova dot 19 pandemic uh coven 19
pandemic what it's doing to our country
so he's seeing the worst of this and you
know again
i'll say this too hey listen he has the
luxury of saying i'm a doctor he and i
can do that going on you know further in
life a lot of guys in football don't
have that luxury no football is it
that's what they're best at and they're
gonna have to try to make that work and
go from there but you know uh this is a
tough blow for a team that we know is uh
the super bowl contender but they made
an appropriate signing this off this
weekend too
to make up for you know uh the the the
missed right guard here and i do renee
tardy i guess choco when i say his name
um so they at least have made some
action there to fill in that with
calachio semoli and we'll see if that
works i still think he's got some good
years in in front of him as well
i mean there was a time when assembly
was the mark yeah offensive lineman and
free agency when he jumped from the
ravens to the raiders it kind of fell
apart for him latter years in oakland
and then with the jets it didn't work
out i don't know that this is apples to
apples but at least it shows the chiefs
have a plan and they're going to do what
they have to do to replace
duvernay tardif and and you got to be
ready and this is why when we brought up
the question last week of the chiefs of
the field for super bowl 55 you got to
go with the field because you never know
how this virus is going to affect a
given team now we didn't anticipate that
a starting offensive lineman would
immediately opt out for 2020 but we
never know what's going to occur who's
going to test positive when a key player
is going to be absent for a key game
it's just part of the uncertainty for
this year for the opt outs and again i
i've been trying to get a feel for how
many guys yeah that's the same what do
you think
what do you think your gut tells you i
mean i i don't think it's going to be a
much a handful throughout the whole
league is what my gut is telling me
single digits is what people keep
telling me but here's the thing
you don't have to make a decision now
now it's clear that duvernay tardif knew
that this was what he was going to do no
matter what he was waiting for the deal
to be finalized he'd already made his
decision and he announced it right away
everybody else has another week there's
no reason to announce it there may be
guys who know they're going to do it but
why not take the full week
and
and think about it maybe you wake up one
day and change your mind once you tell
the team you're out you are out period
even if you tell them you're out before
the deadline so there could be some guys
who are thinking about it there could be
some guys who are contemplating it
and there's no reason if they haven't
made a final decision to tell anyone
about it
today you know flip it around how many
guys have said definitively they're not
opting out now that doesn't mean that
everyone is thinking about it but
there's no reason there's no reason to
say it now unless you are 100 certain
that it's what you're going to do a
couple of things to keep in mind too
there is a stipend that's available for
the players who opt out if you will fall
into the high risk category
you get 350 000. if you don't fall into
the high risk category you get 150 000
it's not free money it's an advance on
salary to be earned next year so when
you do come back for example duvernay
tardif will get 150 000 his salary this
year was supposed to be 2.75 million
he'll make 2.6 million in 2021 his
contract tolls a full year
he gets 150 000 now he gives up 150 000
later and if and you know at one point a
gm said to me well if i'm an undrafted
free agent i know i've got no chance of
making the team i just opt out and i get
150 000
the problem is if you don't make the
team next year you owe 150 000 which
means you're going to have a team
potentially chasing you around as a
former employee to pay back that 150 000
is that just the undrafted free agents
like no it's anybody no you got to do it
you've got to do tardy if he got his 150
000 he goes in there next year and they
somehow cut him from the team wow he'd
have to pay back 150 000.
now it's quite possible the chiefs would
say we're gonna go
right right yeah right but but that's
the way it works because i think they
didn't want they didn't want that
category of guys yeah to think you know
what
i i'm probably done anyway
and i'll just take the free this is
basically my gold watch on the way out
the door you know i wasn't really i was
probably this is gonna be my last year
and i really am not into it i'm worried
about this i'm worried about that i'm
good i'll opt out i'll take the money
right and then see you later so i think
they don't want it to be abused they
want it to truly be there as money that
helps guys get through this year with
the understanding that they will be back
next year but it does give it gives the
team a little a little uh weapon for
2021 if there are some guys that are on
the fence that that did opt out uh if
they get cut they have to pay that money
back but i i agree with you we're not
going to be talking i believe about a
lot of guys who do it at the end of the
day guys want to play football and
there's too much money on the line and
that is where i think it's going to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports